hello Daniels how was the game uh
against Magnus the game was boring
so what do you think about the
um opening B3 did you expect
yeah I mean okay you can normally
prepare something for uh for each
tournament yeah and I was not as a first
guy here to very to face this one this
thing
but also I didn't really prepare like I
saw it I saw that he played a few times
I was like how Okay one two three
probably I mean whatever if you if you
play this reason this is my list for a
sort of
and also like did you expect Catalan
here what do you think about that like
like I mean against Magnus
you normally don't don't expect some
particular line you basically expect to
be surprised normally and uh yeah as the
storms I got exactly what I expected but
one B3 also is not the worst uh is the
worst way for for being surprised you
know okay well 1v3 is not exactly a
killer like he he's basically doing it
because he he's trying to I mean avoid
some Theory and he basically otherwise
on uh you know he's uh like ability to
thought class people
you just play yeah I mean if you can now
play you'll like that and okay what can
you do yeah then you would lose after
one E4 as well yeah so yeah one plus
three was a was a nice surprise
thank you so much